d'euros limonest vrai qu'en direct pour
touche pas à mon poste vous nous fassiez
faumont doute parce que c'est pour mon
cours et parce que j'essaie d'imiter
alors vous allez nous faire deux trois
voire comme ça le prochain parce qu'elle
a une voix incroyable vous allez voir
chez vous vous êtes coûts et à chaque
fois il scotché à chaque fois que
véronique fait quelque chose alors
véronique on restait pas marrer par
isabelle boulay il ya une chanté par le
mois il y avait un imitateur
extraordinaire qu'il n'est pas content
oui qui fait les guignols votre mac
guignols n'aurait pas la merde quoi
alors on commence avec isabelle boulay
alors tu es prêt c'est bon c'est bon
c'est parfait alors c'est vrai je ne
sais plus comment te dire je ne trouvais
leur chante tout chante passer du champ
droit de parler
non non non en fait le fait que vous
faites le bouille alors on va pas le
faire seul et puis moi je moi je vais
lui offrait d'accord au part de moi je
ne suis plus commentées mais ni comment
te parler au parlement
merci des rallyes après on l'a on a un
hasard ou nasale
allez-y je vais arriver d'en bas vous
allez voir alesi commencé j'arrive je
veux de l'amour la joie de la bonne
humeur à mon bonheur
je crevais la main sur le canada annonce
ensemble découvrir ma liberté oubliés
dont tous vos clichés
bienvenue dans ma réalité
liu xiaobo est ce qu'on va pas se faire
en commun soit une petite vanessa
paradis
ok ça va aller je vais arriver dans deux
choisi ali commençait dès marie lavoie
dit si tu essaies fragilité de vivendi
l'amour qui sommeille tant souffrir ma
folie mon envie mais à lui dit mon idée
[Applaudissements]
encore un dernier petit truc auquel on
ne regarde que lui
enfin
mais chut
[Musique]
là
ah bin là
[Musique]
american fois
m